hello and welcome back to the shitty
signs you so today we're going to
address the question is epigenetic aging
refers to both so understanding aging is
a really exciting topic right now with
age being a major risk factor for
multiple movements mobilities this video
was Hegel's on a journey from
understanding the basics of epigenetics
to how epigenetics can be used to
determine biological age and whether by
modifying epigenetic marks aging can be
slaves or it seems to be suggested by
this recent paper were fast so firstly
what is epigenetics so there are many
definitions of what epigenetics is but
in my mind epigenetics includes own on
genomic information storage in cells and
so this includes understanding gene
networks so much genes are expressed and
then involves chromatin structure and
also the post translational
modifications or PTMs
to histone proteins and so these
modifications can involve methylation or
a sensation and so histone proteins are
proteins that are kind of DNA is wrapped
around these histone proteins and that
creates chromatin and that makes up pure
nucleus and these modifications are made
either fear proteins such as DNA or
histone modifying enzymes or
transcription factors or fear or any
such as non-coding RNAs that can also
alter the epigenetic patterns so that
brings us on to what happens to
epigenetic marks during aging so you
type this interview and you'll see an
explosion of information this really is
a hot topic at the moment and I've even
talking about epigenetic changes in
connection with the hallmarks of aging
before in a previous video and I'll put
the link to the video in the description
for you but in this video we really want
to get to the bottom of what happens to
epigenetic marks during aging and
considering that epigenetic marks can be
reversible how many were fasting
and in an attempt to prevent or to slow
down the process of Aging and so another
thing that I think I failed to mention
so far is that epigenetic marks can
alter gene expression patterns and also
how the cell responds to DNA damage the
nuclear signaling and so this is the
implications of the epigenetic marks so
during aging a variety of changes to the
epigenetic marks have been seen and say
this includes global heterochromatin so
that involves compaction of the
chromatin there's changes in the histone
marks and their modifications
there's also DNA hypo methylation on a
global scale and there's also hyper
methylation to increase methylation at
these so called CPG Islands which we'll
talk about bit more later and so this
also has invariant remodeling of the
nucleosomes and changes in non-coding
RNA abundance and cysteine variants
which is just different versions of this
things and so lastly it's also thought
that during aging there's also real
localization of the chromatin modifiers
themselves and this idea has been put
forward by David Sinclair and his lab
focuses on understanding this process in
more detail and he also has a recent the
couch is all about aging and longevity
and so I kind of want to read that
something so I might do I guess
anyway back to the point of this video
so what are the consequences of these
changes in epigenetic marks during aging
so one thing is that these changes and
marks obviously they alter a gene
expression but they can also result in
genomic instability which could increase
the mutation rates and chance or cells
becoming cancerous and these gene
expression changes can also allow
freedoms of DNA that was previously
silent such as retrotransposons
to now be expressed and that can have
severe consequences for a cell so given
that we observe changes in epigenetic
marks during aging can we use and
identify these epigenetic marks to
determine somebody's biological age so
the concept that I'm describing here or
also referred to as biomarkers
the idea is that we want biomarkers to
identify and validate and interventions
that could extend the human health span
and the life span but to be regarded as
a biomarker it must fulfill certain
criteria for them to be followed so
these criteria includes the biomarkers
being a better prediction of lifespan
than chronological age agile age and it
must be able to monitor a basic process
that underlies the aging process not
just the effects of the disease and so
this is the challenging one because it
can be quite hard to distinguish the
effects of chronic diseases from normal
aging and also another criteria it must
be something that we could test
repeatedly without causing harm to the
patient and lastly a muscle working
model organisms as a biomarker of age so
that any interventions could first be
tested and them before that then applies
to human testing so using epigenetics as
a biomarker for aging has also been
referred to as the epigenetic clock
because literally any times ticking away
I guess I don't really and now I've
drawn a clock of ears anyway these
epigenetic clocks take into account the
methylation status of millions of
differents cpg dinucleotides in the
human genome because they have been seen
to change of age and so what's been seen
is that the CPG Island cervicals gets
hyper methylated as you age the
methylation increases as you can see in
this graph here i'm so by taking a
sample of somebody's DNA and measuring
the methylation status at various
different CPG sites in a genome you can
use the mathematical algorithm to
calculate their epigenetic age and this
epigenetic age can then be correlated
with the chronological age to see
whether or not this person has a
positive or a negative association with
a chronological age as you can see shown
on this graph here and they just also
want to point out that there seems to be
a rapid or more rapid increase in the
methylation during growth and
development and so I actually
stole this graph from recent nature a
few genetics article so I guess you can
call me the sneaky science Shane today
moving on
given that we can measure the
methylation status and we know the
epigenetic marks can be reversed
is it possible to reverse the epigenetic
age so as I mentioned earlier in this
video
this paper seems to be the first reports
of an increase in predicted human
lifespan by currently accessible aging
intentions and they have evidence that
they have in theory reverse the
epigenetic age so what did they actually
do so there's paper they set up this
trend trying trails right trying to
speak with stands for the thymus
regeneration immune arrest arranged in
an insulin might occasion and they did
this in a select group of healthy men
aged between 51 to 65 years and they
then used recombinant human growth
hormone to try to prevent or even what
they say to reverse the aging by
regenerating and restoring the thymus so
why the thymus so one of the
characteristics of the aging process
seems to be thymic in pollution
literally shrinking of the finest and
this has the consequences of reducing
the immune cell population and so thymic
and pollution is linked to age-related
increases in cancer incidents autoimmune
diseases inflammation atherosclerosis
and all cause mortality and it's even
been seeing that centenarians have
maintained an immune function so by
targeting the thymus it seems possible
that you kids prevents or slow down the
aging process and as I said they used
human growth hormone to do this but
because this has a consequence of
inducing hyper intially mia they also
use two other compounds metformin and
DHEA as well to try and counteract this
effect or they metformin for example is
also known to maybe have anti-aging
effects and in this trial they use four
different
epi two
clocks to give a readout or measurement
of the epigenetic age to correlate it
with the chronological age so firstly
it's important to notice that they saw
that the epigenetic age was lower than
the chronological age hence the negative
scale and the axes and interestingly
what they saw was that in all of the
different age estimators that they used
the rates of aging regression
accelerated after nine months of
treatment
so obviously epigenetic age doesn't
include all aspects of aging but since
it's currently our best measure of
biological age is interesting and
exciting to see these kind of results
the questions that that they growing now
is what is the mechanism of this
reversal and what actually is the causes
of the changes in the first place so yes
this is a huge topic but it gives hope
that were slowing the process of Aging
could it be possible for altering
epigenetic marks so thanks for listening